Rangers from the El Dorado bird reserve
ride 3,000 meters up to San Lorenzo
ridge on their motorcycles the reserve
the Rangers are monitoring in the sierra
nevada de santa marta is a private one
created by the pro Ava's bird protection
foundation among other things the area
is home to a species of parrot that's
threatened with extinction the Santa
Marta parakeet is found nowhere else in
the world there are only about 120
specimens here in the bird reserve their
natural habitat is disappearing Lorenzo
Mora explains y por la de Forest as your
they're endangered for many reasons
local increasing deforestation use of
the land for agriculture hunting and
illegal trapping for the pet trade human
activity has hit these species
especially hard the cloud forest in the
mountains is the breeding habitat of
this rare parrot species the Rangers
have hung up more than 50 nesting boxes
here they check regularly to see if the
artificial nests are being used
santa marta parakeets prefer to nest in
20 meter tall wax palms to their delight
the rangers find three parakeet chicks
though they belong to another species
the less endangered starlet fronted
parakeet carlos rojas explains the
strategy sandy gundam aspirin we hang up
the boxes where the santa marta
parakeets are usually spotted and where
they roost if that doesn't work we move
them elsewhere in our city under system
jogando reverted the farmers in the
region play an important role in species
protection a great deal of coffee is
cultivated in the sierra nevada de Santa
Marta right now the bushes are in full
bloom the pro abbas conservationists
advise the coffee farmers on how to make
their plantations especially bird
friendly carlos rojas tells us that
shade-grown coffee is cultivated under
large trees con los arboles kissin sobre
el cabello by preserving individual
trees the shade-grown coffee plantations
provide a connection between the
remaining forested areas acting like
bridges so the birds can fly onwards
shade-grown coffee provides a habitat
for the birds more and more amateur
ornithologists are discovering
Colombia's bird life bird watchers are
an important source of income for
promise and ecotourism is helping
preserve the biodiversity of this
Colombian mountain range
you